bonjour j'espère que ça va tenir je suis
actuellement assis sur un lit
cette caméra est maintenue par des
coussins je suis arrivé à 30,03 c'est ce
que j'ai cru entendre on dit pas ou
parce que c'est un ou paraît donc on
barre on le réveille et on remplace par
un e à peu près donc c'est l'oms je suis
arrivé en trombe the il y à quelques
heures il est actuellement 18h30 et il
fait noir comme dans la nuit noire
il faisait déjà noir quand je suis
arrivé en fait parce que comme on est
tout au nord de la norvège au dessus du
cercle polaire il fait nuit très tôt la
nuit s'allonge de plus en plus dur de
plus en plus longtemps et d'ici novembre
mi novembre fin novembre je sais pas
trop ils arriveront dans la nuit polaire
où il fera nuit tout le temps le bonheur
et moi je ne verrai pas ça parce que je
reste une semaine
enfin bref donc je suis je me suis mise
en route hier de lille vers paris et ce
matin je me suis levé très tôt 4h30
c'était dur j'ai fait paris francfort
francfort oslo oslo 3 et à oui au fait
ce n'est pas de micros je n'ai pas
remarqué de micro avec moi si j'étais
déjà assez chargé donc désolé pour une
fois ça sera le son de l'appareil photo
et rien d'autre j'espère que ça vous
satisfera quand même parce que j'ai
décidé de faire un blog de ce voyage en
fonction des images que j'aurais
j'espère normalement je devrais avoir
des belles images parce que je ne veux
pas rester à 32 demain je m'en vais déjà
et le but de ce voyage c'est de passer
une semaine sur un bateau donc demain on
vient me chercher en m'amène au bateau
et à bord on va observer principalement
d or qu on va aussi voir tout ce qui
passe en faune marine
il peut y avoir des baleines par exemple
on va dans les paysages des fjords des
aurores boréales j'espère et tout ça je
vais essayer d'en faire des belles
photos et de filmer géant par kengo pro
aussi qu'on va prêter pour
sous l'eau pour filmer un petit peu en
subaquatique
parce que le but c'est également de
plonger donc ces qui organise ça ça fait
à peu près vingt ans que tous les hivers
on fait des expéditions en norvège
le but est d'observer des orques
principalement comme je les dis parce
que cette période là ils viennent en
norvège pour manger du hareng
principalement et le problème dans cette
année et du coup je sais pas si on
pourra plonger comme d'habitude
d'habitude ils plongent avait et qui
disent bonjour sous l'eau ils font ce
qu'on appelle des interactions enfin
voilà les orques s'intéresse aux mains
et réciproquement
parfois pour toujours et par contre
cette année il ya une autre famille
d'orques qui a des marques et si j'ai
bien compris parce que ça fait une
semaine qu'ils ont repris les
expéditions et c'est alors que là au
lieu de chasser de manger du hareng ils
chassent des phoques
vous avez peut-être déjà vu des vidéos
ou les orques s'échouent sur les plages
pour aller choper les phoques et bien là
c'est ce qu'ils font cela et ça crée un
peu plus parce que nous quand on est
dans l'eau on ressemble un peu à des
gros phoque avec nos combinaisons
donc je ne sais pas si le comment on va
plonger si on va plonger dans le pire
des cas et marc veyrat déjà enfreint
déjà une part beau séjour d'une semaine
en bateau à voir des beaux paysages et
de cause animaux et je pense que ça sera
dans tous les cas très bien donc je vais
filmer ça le plus possible si j'arrive à
avoir des images sous l'eau c'est encore
mieux et ça va être bien
c'est le voyage donc je rêvais de faire
depuis des années dès que j'ai commencé
à bosser j'ai réservé aux voyages et à
manger suis donc je suis heureuse même
si là je suis crevée s'assoit sur noir
mat est crevé mais heureuse
donc voilà il est 18 heures 40 à présent
et je vais pas tarder à aller dormir ce
que la fatigue mais ça va être très bien
et je vous dis à bientôt pour vous allez
tout voir d'un coup en fait juste la
suite
ouais avant de revenir sur le
déroulement de ce voyage j'ai quand même
donner mes impressions
là je suis ces derniers jours je suis de
retour à l'hôtel
ça a été une semaine très difficile
desjoyeaux est vraiment une super
ambiance
des gens très sympas j'ai fait des
rencontres et belles rencontres
mais j'ai pas fait de rencontres avec
les orques malheureusement c'est il ya
eu deux années très très bonne avant que
j'arrive là où les orques rentrée très
tôt dans le fjord parce qu'en fait je
l'avais dit je crois dans la première
vidéo que en hiver les arts viennent
manger du hareng et le hareng dès qu'il
fait froid il rentre dans le fjord et
donc les orques aussi et cette année le
hareng sont en retard ils sont pas
encore rentrés dans le fjord ils sont
vos large et donc les orques sont un peu
dispersé et ça a été une semaine du coup
on a cherché les orques et où on les a
pas trouvés aujourd'hui dernier jour on
a aperçu deux ailerons de faim de
nageoire dorsale d'orques un mâle et une
femelle
moi personnellement je suis pas sûr de
les avoir vus cenal ses nageoires
mais on est on sait quand même préparé
on allait en petit bateau on était prêt
à plonger mais on n'a pas plongé parce
qu'on a retrouvé les orques après donc
le but de ce voyage c'était vraiment ça
observé les offres que c'était quelque
chose dont je rêvais depuis
depuis tout petit je pense par sa soeur
emilie et puis quand j'ai appris
l'existence de ce type de voyage j'ai
rêvé d'y aller donc c'était il ya trois
ou quatre ans je pense que j'ai appris
l'existence de ce type de voyage enfin
de cette expédition là j'ai réservé il
ya un an et demi
et là ça y est c'est le moment sauf que
non ça va pas marcher
donc c'était vraiment un gros rêve pour
moi évidemment du coup il va falloir que
j'y retourne donc dès que j'aurai les
moyens c'est tout j'en pars dans deux
ans dans trois ans je sais pas mais je
vais faire ça mais donc c'était assez
dur quand même
l'équipe a fait son maximum on sait que
c'était vraiment une semaine
exceptionnellement difficile que ce
début d'année n'est pas facile qui a eu
dès cette année de façon y avait des
gens qui étaient déjà venus une fois
deux fois et qui ont dit qu'ils avaient
fait des plongées magnifique des
rebelles rencontre avec les ordres des
interactions vraiment super et lamont
cette semaine n'ont donc on sait que
c'est la faute de personne c'est juste
malchance mauvaises conditions
modification du comportement des harengs
et donc des orques qui n'est pas
prévisible
en plus de ça on a eu quelques jours de
mauvais temps aussi bref c'est pas de
chance c'est tout c'est comme ça j'ai
quand même vu des paysages magnifiques
j'ai super bien manger c'était délicieux
et puis il y avait une bonne et une
bonne ambiance mais bon du coup on c'est
vrai qu'on a passé pas mal de jours en
mer à partir le matin espérait vendre
les orques ne pas les voir
donc vous verrez sur les vidéos que j'ai
fait beaucoup de vidéo ou c'est juste
on navigue on voit les beaux paysages et
voilà on se balade est un petit peu
aussi on a fait du jacuzzi
mais il y avait quand même beaucoup
d'attentes
heureusement je suis quelqu'un qui ne
s'ennuie jamais et qui est très patient
donc moi ça me correspondait style de
vacances mais sait on a beaucoup attendu
espéré scrutait l'horizon pour pas grand
chose au final pour rien la plupart des
jours donc c'était des journées peu
compliqué et puis du coup c'était jeudi
à l'avant-dernier jour vraiment ça
commençait à me peser à mettre un coup
au moral je suis contente qu'aujourd'hui
on les avait presque vu parce que même
si au final j'ai rien vu ça a quand même
fait quelque chose quoi je sais qu'ils
étaient là pas loin et c'est comme ça
c'est pas si works est pas le marineland
on peut pas prévoir gilles mallet à
telle heure on aura d or qui voit là on
va plonger avec eux ils vont nous faire
une danse du ventre non c'est pas ça
c'était la nature et c'est bien comme ça
tout juste pas de chance mais j'aurais
sûrement plus de chance la prochaine
fois j'espère c'est pas possible d'avoir
entendre la chance de 28 mois et j'ai
plongé quand même aussi vous verrez ou
pour rien je suis plongée g plongeurs
mais young a aussi dans le fjord c'était
très froid ça j'ai pas de vidéo par
contre on n'a pas vu d'avoir borea non
plus c'est ms deux objectifs voire des
heures voire des aurores boréales et par
n'ont aucun des deux et en fait il y en
a eu une ma roue mais tu es venu me
réveiller en disant que justin et des
aurores boréales
je suis sorti vers le temps de
m'habiller de mettre un pull et puis on
m'a dit ah mais non mais elle a duré
qu'une minute et les partis les coups
furent tournées brochet et après des
revenus auparavant
donc voila c'était une semaine où on est
passé à côté de tout ce qui était tout
ce pour quoi je voulais venir mais c'est
tout c'est comme ça c'était quand même
des vacances et comme ça je sais que je
peux revenir
[Musique]
m
à
et
me
[Musique]
en
oh
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
noui l'autre
[Musique]
m
bon mari mort
mal de gens
je
et
[Musique]
pourtant pas ce que dame
mais ne sait jamais
je sais
celle ci
m
[Musique]
c
le talent de nous
meyer
[Musique]
time
m
je
[Musique]
m
mr
non
[Musique]
m
d
là
[Musique]
[Rires]